so you've been out there fighting for
these lefty principles but you do talk
about this a lot that there now seems to
be an alliance between what has become
the left and Islamism and these are
should be things that are completely in
conflict and yet yeah I'll tell you why
today the left is led by academics and
what I call millionaires mimicking
misery when was the last time you heard
of somebody going to a steel mill who's
a leftist right left the idea of justice
that Bernie Sanders talks about even to
a certain degree dishonestly but she
does talk about it is Hillary Clinton
she doesn't know a damn thing about
social justice Lippe and what i'm
digressing but that's a whole other joke
okay but this notion of social justice
once accomplished which means everybody
getting public school getting a
breakfast having a minimum wage it's
reached a ceiling now those who might
have a problem with the United States of
America as a hate system they they they
dislike America because they have
nothing else to hate so the Chomsky's of
this world a brilliant people but I
think they are diseased in a way that
they can't find anyone else to hate and
they they are relating to the Islamists
because the Islamists hate America and
so this what I call Sharia ball tourism
is on the one side is the naivete of the
American academic left and on the other
side a false pretense of Islamists or
women and fancy he jobs and stilettos
sprinting sprinting the language of
left-wing lingo you know they've learned
that in the Women's Studies Gender
Studies PhD it has got nothing to do
with social justice so is that is that
the most dangerous part that we're
seeing on camp
is right now what everyone's calling
intersectionality that all of these all
of these groups on the left they don't
necessarily have anything to do with
each other but if they can figure out
who's the most depressed they just latch
on to each other and then they create a
whole other monster it's make-believe
because I don't see these people
involved in the genuine political look
at the American election system yeah as
much as people criticize it can you
imagine an election campaign that long
in Canada I mean for goodness sake the
last Prime Minister pushed it from 40
days to 60 days and give us a oh my god
what are we gonna do I can't even
imagine people coming out in minus
freezing temperatures to attend simple
rallies I'm the last time I saw this
wasn't in Pakistan I I simply am
fascinated at the involvement of whether
they are New England you know bright
left-wing people that I see or even
Bible Belt folks from Alabama I just see
the involvement in society as a very
left-wing idea you know that's really
interesting because to me I guess if we
could split the difference between the
short election cycle of Canada and ours
which has now become a two-year
operation I guess if we could somehow
get them in between I think that would
be better because the yours is very
short but always it ours is way too long
I know that but it's when you retired
like me 65 years and over it's fun time
is a statement who doesn't want to see
Donald Trump listen right I know it's
good for us on Twitter I don't know how
good it is for the for the nation but I
think look at it this way I have friends
what equally comfortable either Bernie
Sanders or Donald Trump and we we sat
down the other day about eight of us and
we were discussing late why are we
attracted to build these guys and the
essence is that it's only these two who
talk like human beings you know that
Gloria Borger
come in D my god I think they were made
the factory sometimes that s SP that
woman who comes as she dug up oh my god
they are almost as it Oh made in Taiwan
and just put there and it's shocking on
the other hand you see some of the women
who are reporting for CNO Hosting's
brilliant minds you did John King you
look at these you just get rode back
into my goodness these guys are
professionals but mixing it up are those
that are totally they have no idea
what's going on but there are people who
do and I think both Donald Trump and
Bernie Sanders know this world better
than all the other guys in the race yeah
so is that is that the fascinating piece
here that we now have you know a
democratic socialist or a socialist
Democrat whatever whatever we're calling
him right now and we have sort of this
ultimate capitalist and what they have
in common is that they're both against
the system which i think is really
ironic because Trump has used the system
to make a lot of money and and and
Bernie's used it to become a successful
politician but they're using the system
to change the system that's actually
very American it is but they are being
followed because they are natural human
being speaking then they don't come
anywhere close to s cup whatever her
name is a Gloria they are like you and
me they don't read out of scripts people
associate Frank a honesty from both and
that is why even at his worse
Don from how many imagine winning forty
six percent of the Hispanic vote I mean
somebody in Canada treated Oh someone
explain this to me I said I'll explain
to you you're cut off you can't even get
over how your Chardonnay smells or how
you take your coffee you know even
Starbucks wants you to be a graduate in
Latin just to get a cup of faith before
these guys a talking ordinary English so
what people are fascinated by the two if
you are if you're a centrist or if
you're someone on the left or you're a
swing voter doesn't Trump for all the
crazy things that he says wouldn't you
much prefer and even if you're on the
Left wouldn't you much prefer a trump
president than Rubio because Rubio's far
more right-wing when it comes to
abortion and religion and gay rights and
foreign policy he's smart look I am more
I don't think left and right count
anymore I think honesty and commitment
and lack of corruption is what I seek
for when I find out that my shakes I
work ten years in South Arabia worth
with the biggest conglomerate over there
I find their names in the Clinton
Foundation list I'm shocked
yeah what the Saudis doing there when I
look at Obama bending over 90 degrees to
hold the hand of the Saudi King I saw a
picture of Hillary Clinton bending over
to meet a Saudi prince I know what makes
them Bend I lived there I won't bend to
anyone neither do they expect anyone to
bed
nobody mends over but both Obama and
Hillary Clinton in their gestures in
their movements tell everyone we've got
something to hide and you are dumb
enough not to understand that so and so
that's basically that's basically money
I mean it's basically oil and money lots
of it if Pakistan can buy an American
Undersecretary of State you know I'm
talking about how files are found in a
hotel or no wait I think this is going
over me know this is the former boxer
the American ambassador who died in the
air crash for general Gerald Huck oh yes
yes yes yes yes right
the Undersecretary of state for what do
you mean Pakistan that file ended up in
Pakistan's hands huh the reason she's
not prosecuted is she was just let go
she was assistant secretary of state be
handled by the Pakistani side if Park
some can do that can you imagine what
the Saudis do to you and all of you
Americans have been told Iran very bad
very very bad it aah aah
Iran doesn't have a slingshot to hit you
still but she you know the Shia that
you'd beat themselves while just to
prove that they are Muslim and the way
she has proved that they are Muslim is
that if the Sunni says Jew very bad the
Shia says I say 1000 times and the
Americans at his release take that
seriously it's the sheer trying to tell
the Sunni I am a better Muslim than you
and in a very pathetic way screaming at
Jews just to prove his Muslim Ness yeah
in the meantime the Saudis have
manipulated the American system you
don't go to be the second largest
investor in Twitter and instead abag in
every American University what is how
the interest in Berkeley how did
University of California urban just last
week rejected a two chairs by a Hindu
group or one how many go to follow this
and say it's Saudi money right so is
some of that I think some of that when I
hear that so like the Saudi prince who
owns the second you know the second
largest amount of Twitter I don't think
it's a coincidence that this guy got
involved with Twitter and now just in
the last two weeks we've seen you saw
this new trust and Safety Board on
Twitter and now they're it's all these
people on the left so we talked about
that Alliance before and suddenly
they're picking all of these people to
now police Twitter and just in the last
couple weeks we've seen some big-time
conservatives either have been kicked
off Twitter or or quit themselves so
that really shows the danger of what's
going on here right Facebook security is
handled in a city that is run in India
there were true monopolies of Islamists
that's Hyderabad throughout 2014 I spent
four months in Facebook prison oh you've
been bad you've been bad
and and kicked-off zillion times right
how it got to some people in India who
were told that he's being shut out
because his security is handled by
Islamists using the Facebook people know
that the private company who handles the
security in India who could imagine that
I found that out I went to the damn
office Wow
I said come on I want to meet you guys
like it boggles your mind and we I've
got no resources but if people who do
not have resources but have no access to
the media who thanks to you and thanks
to the internet connection we can talk
about this and people can listen but we
are screwed unless and until we wake up
who's the real bad dude in this you know
it's really fascinating and I and I'm
glad we're talking about this because I
can see the through line my friend
Faisal Saitama thar who you might know
Faisal has been banned from Facebook
several times I have never met a more
decent person who has escaped
persecution who has made his life about
helping people and all the values that
we hold dear he's been banned and just
this week he connected me with a group
of X Muslim atheists you've been banned
now from Facebook this week and he was
seeing if I could help him and it's like
how is this happening it's hard to
believe it's happening I'll give I've
deciphered this I've been I couldn't put
on the no-fly list of the Toronto Star
the Global Mail the National Post all
newspapers that I've written for every
religion for them the method they uses
they've got a thousand people willing to
send out individually crafted email just
yes to editors and white men who have a
fetish for hijab this is a phenomena
beyond me I can't it's and I think whole
lot of liberal white men when they see a
woman with a beehive cone-shaped hijab
and in stilettos and red lipstick their
pal the woman goes and says well this is
in
Slama phob you know mr. Fattah hates and
he's paid by the Jews and the Hindus and
I don't know how many people pay me and
every other place shut me down
not just me I've counted five while the
liberal Canadian writers of us will
involve on the field to ban Sharia in
Canada they identified us they put these
women in those offices as a purple BOTS
term a print not apprentices interns and
I could write a book about what is or
what what's going on and how senior
editors are being manipulated how is it
that the New York Times is open to every
woman who would come forward and write
something that is patently apologizing
about or anti-american but even as an
alter or as a weekly called icon no
right and they're doing this they're
doing this to Muslim women - because
Astra nobody who I'm sure you're
familiar with she she she's considered
not to write Muslim and who judges who's
a write Muslim is white female feminists
like look at what's happening in in
Ottawa yeah I want to talk about this
yeah go ahead oh my god they've declared
on a day before Iran's election where
the single biggest issue is the right of
women to go out and not be in that
chastity belt strong around their heads
since 1979 on one hand we've got that
election on Friday how do we greet it on
Thursday the City of Toronto ah is going
to have a hijab solidarity day this is
not some right-wing Alabama town where
or a backward place somewhere in Mexico
that is organizing this this is one of
those liberal cities in the world with a
left of centre government in power with
a mirror sensible but deep
I soaked in white guilt and they are
going to do that I wrote in the Ottawa
Sun today I said you're celebrating the
most repressive symbol of SLAM ISM and
you making white women come forward and
then the jihadists were put these wrap
arounds and everybody will say oh she
looks so pretty oh that that's
objectifying Muslim women as if they are
some circus animals when I say oh I love
that puppy what is it oh it's a it's a
you know a Chinese poodle oh no no
that's a bloodhound we are being
downgraded from being human beings to
being exhibits for white liberals to
pity right so this is also interesting
because no other religion and this is
what you know Bill Maher who I think
originally quoted a speech from George W
Bush of all people said the soft bigotry
of low expectations we would never
fetishize the oppressive things that
other religions do on women so for
ultra-orthodox Jewish women that have to
wear a wig we would never have other
women say go out and support them by
wearing a wig we would never have you
know we would never have in honor of
Christian women have a bunch of non
Christians dress up as nuns they would
actually you could do that on Halloween
and it's still ridiculous
its left-wing Orientalism this is racism
that the left is indulging it because
the left knows we are the champions of
anti racism how dare somebody accuse us
and under that protection they are being
totally racist they are treating Muslims
as we are not human beings and they are
patronizing us with their love and
affection yeah so that's I've tried to
bring this point across several times
but that in and of itself is what real
racism is but real that real racism is
saying that if someone's a black
conservative of who I know many to be to
be true to their ideals
saying that oh there there Uncle Tom's
or say or the heart I mean I'm sure I
don't have to tell you the zillion of
horrible things that I've seen written
about you or said about you
that's real racism uh well the point is
that the lift has absolutely no idea how
Google makes money so their textbooks
are well written maybe by progress
publishers in 1952 out of Moscow they're
looking for the chimney stack hmm
there's the factory no Factory where do
they where's the trade union they don't
have a trade union what do they buy they
don't buy anything or do they sell they
don't sell anything where is the storage
where is they have no clue they haven't
yet figured out Google makes billions of
dollars and you suckers don't know how
it's made it's the new economy that Karl
Marx talked about in the communist
manifesto if you'll pick it up he that
guy writing in the shirring winters of
England in deep poverty knew what was
happening these idiots who picked up
like the red mailbox of the 60s you know
without reading anything about the
economic process are profoundly giving
lectures on issues that are social so
homosexuality gender rights abortion how
is this applicable to that farmer in
India who's committing suicide because
there's no rain or because the banking
system has failed him he can't pay back
loans I mean I keep giving examples of
India because India is the future of
humanity I mean it's got what 26
languages six religions they've never
been there's no been a civil war between
any two states I think I think if I'm
not mistaken India was the only country
during the Holocaust that didn't ship
Jews out of its borders right not only
that a fascinating thing you go to the
original Jewish city of Cochin where the
first Jews settled it is also the first
city where the Muslims made a mosque
while Muhammad was alive and today Jew
town in Cochin
is surrounded by Muslim stores Kashmiri
Muslim stuff it's just fascinating if
you visit that Wow
and it so is their actual so there's
real coexistence I mean I know there's
not many Jews left in India but the
still there yeah there is an absolute
absence of anti-semitism in India even
in Pakistan when we were growing up I
that in my book the Jews not my enemy
that there was a movie called that was a
hit to score daughter of the yahoodi
Turkey the daughter of the Jew it was a
Roman adaption of a Roman gladiator
thought of a play in which the hiren was
a Jewish woman
we had Jews and neighbors in my in my
school where we have a went to school
you couldn't imagine the 67 war really
brought all of this back but I see the
India of the future of having people who
have asked often where you come from
from India it's what they were from
China them you got people who fight more
white than anyone in America and I've
seen people who are black who are of
African origin and there's how could a
country that speaks 24 languages and
have so many elections and the worst
thing that happens is a riot and Jay Lee
University in Delhi nowadays where
there's a scuffle going on and everyone
says oh well you see the Hindu
extremists they're very bad well what
are they doing they're not say blow up
them of course they're nasty pieces of
work over there if you're nothing
compared to what Isis or the Muslim
Brotherhood or the Pakistani
jamaat-e-islami are doing they want to
destroy human civilization yeah by the
way we should mention that India is
literally the world's largest democracy
right I mean Modi just won it was the
most people that have ever voted in a
democratic election ever and it has
never ever been accused of voter fraud
oh that's coming that's coming no it
can't come because asked em last three
elections Indian votes are counted on
computer machines there is no paper
involved within an hour of the polls the
results gets transferred and hit and
India does its election over a 10-day
period so not attend appear I think it's
a month it takes but it goes into
segments groups of states and they move
on the result doesn't come out but once
it's done boom it takes hardly an hour
and the total results come out you will
never hear somebody saying oh they were
cheating away you can't cheat for all
the backward industrialization or
whatever they have to progress there on
the frontline of protecting democracy
for them this the value this awful vote
is far more important than the value of
the rupee that's significant
yeah so I wish people knew about this
more and that's why I really enjoyed
your TED talk and and one of the things
that you said about that how the
partition led to sort of it's like
having your arm cut off that it still
exists and you sort of alluded to this
earlier that all of these people whether
they're in Pakistan or India or Kashmir
that they're they're still they're still
dealing with the wounds of being a
nation and having different religions
and all the stuff so I think that's a
perfect segue you basically are the only
person that I have seen on Twitter I
think literally the only person that is
talking about what's happening in
Balochistan right now yeah and I know so
we're doing a lot of history stuff here
so without getting without getting too
deep can you for people that have no
idea that have never even heard of this
place can you explain a little bit it's
like Germany that's the area Germany or
Poland equivalent it's about 5,000 year
old civilization the language is
distinct as a result of British presence
there no some got divided the major part
became an independent state in 1947
parts of Brentwood
to Iran by the British and a small part
of the North went to Afghanistan
so still like Kurdistan I would say
occupied by three other fellow Muslim
countries if it had been occupied by
some Jews it would be in the front of
course you jig
these Jews oh yeah that would get a
little press you know what I'll make a
call to my Mossad guys yeah a BTS blue
builders against Israel yes oh this was
a country equivalent to what is Burma or
salon on Nepal so it became independent
as the first independent state before
India or Pakistan got the independence
the person who got them their
independence through the legal framework
charged them his weight in gold
a hundred and I think it was 145 pounds
of gold bullion that he charged as legal
fees
out of the sincerity they gave that to
him the the the Brits awarded the
freedom it was a state of qalaat I have
documents to that in the New York Times
it was announced India Pakistan and
koloth qalaat was the state of Rajasthan
within a year that same guy Muhammad Ali
Jinnah who's considered backsons founder
ordered Pakistani troops to invade
occupy and kill the and at that time the
state had an upper house a lower house
of parliament and a sort of a
constitutional monarch gone Wow
I've lived there a year in prison in
1970 that's how I came to know because a
very remote area it's as big as Germany
its population is only 8 million so it
is as rich as you can imagine mountains
of gold oil under the ground uranium you
name it a fort city that sits at
now to the Persian Gulf the Straits of
Hormuz strategically wykel to the West
yeah nobody gives a damn
the Chinese have taken that port they
have a nuclear submarine base being
built over there and because there is no
coverage
the Chinese are building a highway over
the Himalayas straight into Balochistan
which will save them 6,000 mile journey
and go straight to where the oil is and
America is sleeping so that's that's
really incredible so I hope that some
people listen this will just Google the
Straits of Hormuz to really understand
how strategic it is and that it's you
know it's right by Iran and I think that
was our soldiers that were our Navy men
were they in the Straits of Hormuz yeah
of course yeah yeah we were we were
right there you see the name to remember
is cavada JW ad you are that's the port
that Biden was the eastern most part of
the Arab Empire it was from the
Sultanate of Oman that had a vase over
there what's happening today is a
genocide almost daily about 50 people 50
bodies are found people are arrested and
they disappear in Canada we managed to
get three or four of the female refugees
imagine being a single woman and running
away into the mountains of hiding we had
to get them over here for the safety
more will come in Charlize you mustn't
say and but the men are being dropped
into ravines they're wells are being
poisoned by the Pakistan military
everything that you read about Cambodia
and the green-orange and how the
Vietcong were treated is happening today
the same jungle warfare is being
implemented surround the village burn
the the Wheatfield and poison the wells
the population has to move and why
because this Chinese highway for which
the Chinese are paying 40 billion
dollars to the Pakistanis they amassed
at 50 MA
on both sides of that highway has to be
depopulated and straight from go either
right up not be populated all Western
reporters go there to Samba they dare
not the Lee's do sets up the BBC the the
only guy who stood up to the Pakistani
was Declan Walsh of Guardium has
expelled there's another female Carlotta
gall of the New York Times she was
beaten up when she filed a report for
the new crime she left nobody can enter
it 16 journalists have been killed from
merely entering that area yeah listen I
there's so much history here and we just
started there's so many more things like
we barely talked about Canada and a
whole bunch of some of the stuff you've
tried to do with progressive Muslims so
I hope you'll you'll come back on but
one final thought what when we talk
about all of this stuff you know I'm
trying to get people to understand other
parts of the world and understand some
of the rich history what's the what's
the one takeaway you would want people
to have to know about more this to get
engaged to understand that there are
parts of the world that our terrible
things are happening that nobody pays
any attention to I would say get
involved in the American political
process on either Bernie Sanders side or
on Donald Trump both these guys know so
much more are willing to talk about it
whether you on the left or the right God
has been very kind to Americans to give
both sides of the political divide
people who are speaking frankly and
honestly you know it's a choice and in
that process you will find out and I'm
hoping somehow that these two gentlemen
would address I can bet you they know
what's happening because Donald Trump as
he mentioned it a couple of times he's
referred to it as to what's happening in
the Middle East and media he's will
never say a bad thing about India you
notice that
he slammed on everybody why because he
sees that the Indians don't desire
anything other than live and let live
but he notices the potential of science
technology innovation and humility it's
not it's not a coincidence that the head
of Google the head of Microsoft you know
major places of excellence that are
Indian Americans coming now more than
any other group for a very small
community they're showing excellent
because the whole Indian ethos is to
learn learn you know and that's where
Americans should need to see India for
what it is it is the future of this
world
yeah well listen I know you're going to
India in a couple weeks and I would love
to visit sometime so maybe maybe you'll
give me a tour in the next year or two
absolutely all right fantastic well
thank you so much Tarek you can find
Tarek on Twitter at Tarek Fattah and you
can learn more about his work and find
out where his books are and all that at
Tarek Fatah